[Music]
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen and
welcome to our afternoon panel on clicks
and mortar the future of physical
University it's an appropriate topic in
many many ways about a century and a
half ago 1852 Henry Cardinal Newman
wrote a book called the idea of the
University in which he examined the
nature of the University what it was to
be a university what it was to be an
educated person ideas have changed
considerably since that time but the
fact remains that the concept of the
University is an important part of our
culture and ever more important these
days how do we define the University we
could define it as a place from the very
very beginning when Plato strolled up
and down with his students in the groves
of academics to the building of the
great universities of Europe Bologna
Paris at Oxford at Cambridge it was a
place to which people came to enhance
further their education to be with
like-minded people so first and foremost
it was a place that it is also a
community it is a community of scholars
people seeking to advance the forefront
of knowledge celebrated from the oldest
times in antiquity Catullus wrote of
plato's academic way inter alia
Silvano's verum karere to seek the truth
in the groves of academia and certainly
that is very very characteristic of MIT
one of the preeminent research
institutions so it is a community of
scholars it's also a community of
students those who come here into other
similar places to consume the knowledge
to take part in it to enhance their own
understanding
so a university is a place it is a
community it is a gateway for many many
people at the outset in the early days
it was a gateway to the wealthier
classes those who had already made it
but needed their gateway to the arts of
culture and refinement that was
befitting their station in society in
medieval Europe it was a gateway to the
church which was the major institution
that transcended national boundaries
later it became a gateway to polite
society for those who again were of the
upper financial and social classes it's
hard for us to imagine and understand
but only in about the past century and a
half has it become a gateway to a
different world not the world of culture
and privilege although what still often
is but to the world of science and
technology this was a world that for
many many years was not considered to be
a world fit for the gentleman one of the
earliest engineering schools of all was
the Acala Polytechnique in France which
was established to assist the military
to better prepare them for the science
of warfare MIT itself was the result in
no small part of the rejection of the
then prevailing university establishment
of the idea that there was a place for
science or technology in the cultured
person the legend goes that Henry Cabot
Lowell
who sponsored a series of lectures for
the education of society at large who's
made his fortune up in the Lowell mills
and it was very interested in popular
education extending it himself a
graduate of Harvard wanted Harvard to
establish a school for the study of the
practical arts namely engineering his
engineering was then called and the
president of Harvard indicated that such
was not a fit study for gentlemen
through through Lowell's
contacts with his various people he came
in contact with William Barton Rogers a
professor down in Virginia and getting
to like Rogers talked with him and
joined with him and assisted him in
establishing what became the
massachusetts institute of technology
the university of today so the concept
of what a university is has changed over
the centuries and only in the past
century and a half has that concept
included the idea of science and
technology as proper and fit subjects
for the university education one reading
which I think will summarize these
concepts of the university not so much
the last not so much the university as a
gateway to science but certainly the
concept of the university is the gateway
to in polite society the university is a
place and the university is a community
a brief reading if you'll bear with me I
think it's well worthwhile and it comes
from a non academic of the last century
and an unusual writer but a wonderful
wonderful story
the writer is Thomas Hardy the story is
Jude the Obscure and to those of you who
are familiar with it it is the story of
a young man who was a great scholarly
natural inclination and or
who had set his sights on going to the
University
the fictitional Christ Minster which we
can all read as as Oxford and the story
begins in chapter 1 I won't read you as
much as a page and but I will jump from
excerpts and piece it together to
illustrate my thesis chapter 1 the
schoolmaster was leaving the village and
everybody seemed sorry why do you go sir
asked the boy and that was Jude Frawley
ah that would be a long story
you wouldn't understand my reason Jude
you will perhaps when you're older I
think I should now sir
well don't speak of this everywhere you
know what a university is and a
university degree it is the necessary
hallmark of a man who wants to do
anything and teaching my scheme or dream
is to be a university graduate and then
to be ordained but going to live that
Christ Minster or near it I shall be at
headquarters so to speak and if my
scheme is practicable at all
I consider that being on the spot will
afford me a better chance of carrying it
out that I would have elsewhere
the schoolmaster leaves Judas sorry is
walking along the road catches a glimpse
of a distant town that in fact is Christ
Minster its distant not only
geographically but its distant also
socially economically politically by any
measure you can think of but he still
dreams he comes across a group of men
who are carrying a load
having come back from Christ Minster and
asks the gentlemen if they are the men
if they can identify the place where it
was he wants to be sure that it's what
he's thinking of and they say is his
Christ Minster does all learning they're
nothing but learning except religion and
that's learning too but I never could
understand it yes there's a serious
minded place you know I suppose
they raise Parsons they're like they
raise radishes and Abed and Noah do take
how many gears Bob five years to turn
Alaric hobbled eat boy chap like you
into a solemn preaching man with no
corrupt passions they'll do it if it can
be done in polishing off like the
workmen they be and turn out with a long
face and a black coat and a waist get in
a religious collar and hat same as they
used to wear in the scriptures so that
his own mother wouldn't know him but
then that's their business
Jude continues his walk in silence
thinking about this and this is the
final paragraph hmm Jude continued his
walk homeward alone pondering so deeply
that he felt timid he suddenly grew
older it had been the yearning of his
heart to find something to anchor own to
cling to for some place which he could
call admirable should he find that place
in this city if he could go there would
it be a spot in which without fear of
farmers or hindrance or ridicule he
could watch and wait and set himself to
some mighty undertaking like the men of
old of whom he had heard the tree of
knowledge grows there he said to himself
it is a place that teachers of men's
spring from and go to it is what you may
call a castle manned by scholarship and
religion he said to himself again it is
a city of light such are the changing
faces of the university their importance
to our culture and these are some of the
topics and others that we will address
now in the question of what is the
university today
what is its place in society our
speakers are evenly divided between MIT
and Harvard I will
[Laughter]
two of the panelists from MIT one from
Harvard and our moderator from Harvard I
will I will leave the introduction of
the panelists through our moderator but
I will introduce our moderator I'm very
very pleased to welcome David war shove
the Boston Globe to moderate our panel
today David is a excellent columnist and
a frequent writer on the topics of
economics he is a graduate of Harvard
has been a staff reporter with the Keene
evening Sentinel in New Hampshire a
reporter for the Pacific Stars and
Stripes during the service digs a
reporter for Newsweek magazine a staff
reporter for The Wall Street Journal an
associate editor of Forbes magazine and
now a columnist for the Boston Globe
is the author excuse me of a number of
books on economics including the idea of
economic complexity published in 1984
economic principles masters and
Mavericks of modern economics published
in 1993 and will shortly be coming out
with his new work the new generation
into the old in economics ladies and
gentlemen David wash
I hate it when I follow a litigator and
I really hate it when I follow a
litigator who does dialect so I'll
exercise my authority to begin with by
asking those of you who can to move
towards the the walls just take a second
and slide down we've got enough people
in the back that if we had a few more
seats on the aisles it would be a big
help just two or three seats easy easy
so so thank you we're going to talk
about clicks and clicks and mortar in
education the differences there of its
five years since the the clicks mania
got going I date that to August of 95
the Netscape IPO it was it was
unbelievable by the standards at the
time the stock was offered at 28 it went
to 78 or 79 that that day and settled at
the end of the day at 58 it raised two
billion bucks like that in a single day
and and and people who had never heard
the like of it they couldn't believe it
it sounds absolutely paltry now it seems
to me some of the air went out of that
that that that bubble in the spring but
the the mortar mania to have started
sometime in the fall in battle mania
yeah with the recognition that
established businesses were gonna be
able to muscle in on this internet
business much more easily than people
had imagined at the beginning I date
that as much as anything to the auto
companies joint joint venture with with
parts but there were a number of things
in the fall and I I think it's it's it's
it's useful to keep in mind that things
come down as well as go up as we talked
about this I just kept the track of the
stories that came across my desk last
week in this area I left an ad that said
that said Barnes & Noble the bookstore
was preparing to offer courses a large
array of courses through the bookstore I
clipped and add that for Dow Jones
University whose ads had said give a
lifetime of powerful investing skills
instead of a necktie online courses
start at $49 I got I got the catalog
from Walden University which you may
think only appears in doonesbury but in
fact it exists in
in st. Paul it offers a half-a-dozen
PhDs it's it's essentially a very
successful old-line correspondence
course business that was bought 25 years
ago by a guy who prepared the a lot of
the Pentagon distance learning the the
manuals by which military personnel take
take courses and and get certificates
he's built it into a very prosperous
little businesses business with with in
each case the doctoral degrees involve a
partnership and in the I don't think
it's a EE but at some engineering degree
with Indiana University requiring some
you know some period of residence that
came on Wednesday Thursday this the new
copy of University Business came in the
mail and the interesting story in it was
about how um I who knows um I it was a
zero expect they have a copy of your
dissertation on file it's the old
university microfilm in Ann Arbor and
and they were bought by Bell & Howell in
1986 and they became the the Research
Division the information and learning
division of Bell & Howell and about
three years ago they they hired the guy
who had been running LexisNexis and and
guess what he's about to spin them out
from Bell & Howell
as a free-standing business in a week
with the auto parts business that they
owned in in Cleveland as a sort of a
side play and they're gonna they're
gonna go into every kind of data bank
business that you can imagine that you
can build off of those those
dissertations that a guy that a guy at
LexisNexis could imagine I had a letter
from a friend Morris Shepherd who was a
physics professor at at Northeastern
until he got bored of it and he bought a
bunch of PCs and networked them together
and found that he was he was very good
at turning out course packs sort of
on-demand textbooks drawn from a variety
of sources journal articles and a
chapter from one text in a chapter from
another text what he was really good at
of course was not the networks but the
permissions
he's done a couple of joint ventures
with copy shops and stuff and he's he's
he's the next time the window opens he's
going to go back to the the IPO market
and try to become a big customs learning
content provider and this morning I was
down at the Harvard Business School and
I heard the Dean
Kim Clark talking about the the office
that they've opened on on Sand Hill Road
in in Stanford up above the Stanford
Business School where for the moment all
they're doing is writing cases and sort
of keeping an eye on it but it wouldn't
take very much to put a put a classroom
adjacent to the 75 faculty worked out
there last year and and what's really
funny is above Sand Hill Road up in
Portola Valley cow
in Silicon Valley so it's very easy to
imagine a kind of a leapfrog game like
that going forward well those were the
things that came to our newspaper office
you don't have to know much to clip
those we have a panel that that really
knows something about this business and
and to them I want to just observe by
way of caution that all those incidents
five or six that I mentioned they all
had to do not with education but with
publishing there were five or six
different outfits that want to get maybe
the latter I'll give a dispensation to
but they're five or six outfits that
really want to get into the publishing
business which is very lucrative but
we're here we're here really to talk
about about education and I'm going to
swipe through the panel twice but Merton
Fleming's is here because she's the
co-director of the MIT Singapore
alliance dick Larsen is here because
because he's the director is that the
right term of the Center for Advanced
learning services here at MIT which is
the cockpit of all of mi t--'s distance
learning operations which are extensive
and Jonathan winters here because he's
the vice president for education at
Harvard Business School Publishing which
if you don't know it you should know is
a bama of talented people that that are
trying to try to extend the HBS brand so
we'll go back and talk about what they
did before they got into this
there's this breaking wave Burton
Fleming has it says that his 50th
reunion will be next year and he'll put
on a red coat then he's the class of 51
here at Tech and and he's a professor of
material science as you know was head of
the department for fifteen years during
its big boost phase and told me that it
was the best job he'd ever had with the
possible exception of fighting fires in
Idaho he's remembered the National
Academies member of the American Academy
of Arts and Sciences which is sort of
the Harvard Harvard would be wing down
here and down and he's a guy great
distinction and he wears a bow tie
dick dick Larson is professor of
operations research was presently of the
Association is also a member of the
National Academy and and two weeks ago
was giving testimony on the hill before
the the Science Committee on distance
learning I don't know whether it's a
good thing or a bad thing and I don't
think he does that Congress should be
holding hearings on distance learning
but it gives you some idea of what the
stakes are and it's reassuring that that
that he should be there instead of
somebody from from Walton college third
Walton University he also has a member
of the National Academy and he's founded
a company Merton have you founded a
company didn't didn't do very well
instead he's the Toyota professor but
dick has a company that does queueing
theory and that's that's been a very
fruitful business for for people from
from tech for many years and and the one
thing that I can tell you that you can't
possibly find out from yourself is that
underneath the table he's wearing cowboy
boots
Jonathan winter Martin actually had that
it's the the score here is Harvard to
MIT to and Princeton one Jonathan
Jonathan winter went to Princeton as an
undergraduate and and he moved out from
there to a variety of enterprises
culminating in a McKenzie partnership
but he went on there from there his real
claim to distinction is that he he went
from there to the mouse he was he was
with Disney and and his great claim to
fame I think is that is that he was one
of the ramrods of Euro Disney cheap now
what he describes as Disney's Vietnam in
France but since has been turned around
I think in general turned around
certainly from the benchmark where it
was headed and and that was sufficient
claim to fame to get him - get him
called to Harvard where as I say he's
with an office no less in the Watertown
arsenal where they where they've all
moved they're serious about this
business so so having said that we're
gonna we're going to we're going to run
through the the three panelists
beginning with Mert each will talk for
15 or 20 minutes and then we're going to
go directly to questions at the end of
that and I'll come back and call on you
[Music]
thank you David you know I'm reminded
following that introduction that in fact
I did start a company know almost 25
years ago and a new technology and that
technology in the materials field is
finally becoming of some practical
importance they're really producing
things and throughout the world
different companies are picking it up
and it took 25 years alan buffered who
many of you know who is now treasurer of
MIT and probably a couple of other
titles I I'm not sure began as a
material scientist as a metallurgist and
he but he got out of it pretty soon went
into finance and did very well after he
said metallurgy is too slow it takes too
long
finances where I'm going to go and he's
done great things with it but but in
terms of speed of things of course this
modern internet Dwarfs even even
financial things of course the finances
are a big part of it but the rate at
which it's changing and the rate at
which is going to change education is of
course very very great now I'm here to
talk about mi t--'s Singapore MIT
alliance and you you will know that when
MIT decides to try something new to move
in a new direction
they we often call it an experiment it
might be an experimental course for
freshmen might be an experimental
program an experimental even method of
governance around the university and in
and that is one way to describe SMA it's
a it's an experiment and it's a very big
experiment it's a hundred million dollar
five-year experiment and and what is it
well you could describe it in a couple
of different ways it's certainly a the
largest worldwide experiment today in
distance education and research I think
maybe even a better way to describe it
is its mi t--'s experiment in learning
how to become
new kind of global University in one
sense we've been a global University at
least since the Second World War with
people coming from all over the world
here I'm sure many of you in this
audience will have come from some other
country to MIT and and I guess because
you're here you see you stayed here but
but that's different than us reaching
out in in some new and different way to
other parts of the of the world and this
experiment is going to provide our
faculty and our students with a with a
view of the world that they wouldn't
otherwise have of course it's an
experiment in in using the internet for
for coursework for education and we're
beaming as a part of this SMA we call it
Singapore MIT alliance we beam courses
through dicks operation every morning of
the week during the semester and every
night and they receive it simultaneously
in Singapore of course 12 hours later so
it's a little unique ours to be teaching
7:00 or 8:00 in the morning and 7:00 or
8:00 at night but it works and by the
way we have in many of these courses
that we're teaching we'll have students
at both ends students in Singapore and
students at MIT a part of the a part of
SMA is research we're giving its all
graduate education so we're giving
master's degrees in doctors degrees
there really are two basic paths are the
traditional research path such as we
have at MIT and have had for many years
and then there's the one-year
professional master's path so on the
research path the students do research
and they have each each student has a
two thesis supervisors one at MIT and
one in Singapore and they have meetings
over the over the internet so the
research employees the internet internet
- as well as the formal teaching of
course not all of the not everything is
over the Internet our
they spend each each of the faculty
members involved in from MIT goes to
Singapore for about two weeks a year two
or three weeks a year to meet face to
face with people there and and they come
here periodically so what is SMA you you
can picture it I think as a virtual
Engineering College its virtual in the
sense that that we don't have our own
buildings and and our faculty are all
part-time at either MIT or one of our
two partners in US National University
of Singapore or MTU Nanyang
Technological University so it's virtual
in that sense its virtual in the sense
that SMA doesn't give a degree and it's
not an MIT degree the the the formal
degree when they walk away with their
masters or doctorate is issued either by
NUS or MTU but in most other respects
it's an independent autonomous
Engineering College we admit our own
students we define our own curriculum we
pass or fail our own students we develop
our own research activities and and so
forth we have five
they're basically academic departments
we call them programs by the way we you
may know English is the is the central
language in Singapore if you walk along
the street you may hear more Chinese
than you'll hear English but English is
the language of business and the
language of Education and and and we
teach in English well that of course
you've gotta decide which English
whether it's American English or British
English and the Singaporeans are moving
very quickly towards American and
American English but somehow we call our
programs we end it with an M es but
there are five of them
we've been gearing up slowly we began
our we admitted our first class just a
year ago July 1 and we in two of our
five departments so to speak or our
programs one was advanced materials
the other was in advanced computing
actually high-performance computing for
engineering systems the professional
masters do students of that program will
will already be graduating and in July
21 will have our first graduation
ceremony in Singapore meanwhile we have
admitted our students for next year and
we've geared up to one more program and
that's manufacturing those students will
be arriving on campus in Singapore
within a few weeks now so we'll have
three programs running next year and
we're in the moment at the moment we're
formulating it takes a little time you
know to get the coursework ready and so
forth we're formulating the the final
two programs one in chemical engineering
but with a actually a biological and
molecular emphasis and then the fifth in
computer science so these are the these
are the five programs the the
collaboration will go for five years of
course could be continued if we if we
decide to and it's an exciting thing for
all concerned
one thing I'll just mentioned before
moving on is that the the faculty I've
mentioned are part-time with SMA and
part-time with another with one of the
other institutions in the case of MIT
each each of these five programs has six
FTEs that is well well I gotta define
that it has six faculty members working
halftime so that a given faculty member
will be teaching in the materials
department for example and 50% of his or
her activities will be in that in that
department and 50% will be in SMA you
know of course you understand that that
we always manage to fit more than a
hundred percent in a year so in a week I
mean so we we have many interesting
tensions the department heads aren't
sure that they want our
faculty to be doing too much in
Singapore and and so we find fun some
very interesting compromises where where
many of the things that we're able to do
on this internet also overlap with
things that benefit the individual
departments and it's worked out most
most successfully in that in that regard
so at the end well I should say really
at the beginning of our of our first
year that's last October we had finished
we had finished one summer of education
that's all it and and most of that we
hadn't really geared up for the internet
yet but we but we were already and we
were practicing ready to go
and we had a governing board meeting and
is this this independent institution is
governed by a group of administrators
from MIT and a group from Singapore and
that governing board met here last early
last fall and we prepared a little video
for them I'm sorry I don't have one more
up to date but I think this video will
give you a little better idea of what it
is that we're that we're doing if we
could turn to the video we have a vision
for the Singapore MIT alliance it is a
vision of a bold new model for
university collaboration we aim to
create world-class academic programs in
areas of strategic importance to
Singapore and to the United States
we aim to form a new paradigm for
distance collaboration on education
research and techno preneur chef SMA
opened its doors on July 1 1999 to its
first class of 64 outstanding students
selected from an applicant pool of 500
after approximately a month of study in
Singapore most of these students came to
MIT for a two and a half week period the
first two days the pre immersion peer
exposed the students to techno preneur
ship activities at MIT with real
examples of startups by MIT faculty and
students the remainder of this day the
immersion period was spent continuing
studies the students had begun in
Singapore not all was work the students
also got to see something of the broader
life and culture of MIT and the Boston
area and also to engage in recreational
activities including an American
barbecue and a duck tour along Boston
streets and waterways following their
stay at MIT the students returned to
Singapore to complete their summer term
SMA is a very pioneering things are new
it's a chance I guess the biggest
impression ever had is actually the MIT
spirit the people are very helpful the
faculty and the students from MIT and
Singapore do you work together ok
beginning September 8th
we have held synchronous distance
education classes approximately 4
mornings and 4 evenings each week who is
with me
ok how about in Singapore good morning
classes on the MIT campus are attended
by regular MIT students the classes are
delivered synchronously using
videoconferencing and application
sharing over Internet to connections how
is this done we transmit 2 streams to
Singapore from our classroom on the MIT
campus one stream consists of all
cameras in the classroom including
cameras showing the presenter the
students the chalkboard and the document
camera these images appear on a large
screen in the classroom in Singapore the
other stream handles just the
computer-generated images such as
PowerPoint slides animations simulations
and other software used by the faculty
in the classroom and in this case this
is the optimal solution these images
appear on a second large screen in the
classroom in Singapore the resulting
collaborative class sessions are of the
highest quality
since the remote participants in
Singapore
receive all computer-generated slides
and graphics on a separate screen and at
the same resolution as those presented
locally at MIT asynchronous delivery is
achieved by using a hybrid of two of em
I t's predominant web delivery platform
systems faculty and teaching assistants
prepare all course materials and upload
them onto the SMA course website this
includes lecture notes quizzes and
announcements students access uploaded
course materials and digitized lectures
in both asynchronous and synchronous
formats the system offers threaded
discussion groups interactive posting
boards that can be sorted by topic
respondent and other criteria and
calendars that include a full range of
course information including links to
specific subject matter for class
preparation on any given day in addition
to the course is being delivered to
students in Singapore 15 SMA students
from the advanced materials program are
on campus this fall taking courses with
regular MIT students they are also
beginning research collaborations with
their MIT thesis co supervisor what does
the future hold for the SMA program
faculty in both MIT and Singapore are
working hard gearing up for the next
academic program to go online
innovations in manufacturing systems
technology will commence next July
preparations are being laid for two
remaining programs to come a year later
my plans are maybe go back home
Singapore and look for start-up starting
up my own business SME is a very very
wonderful program we should actually be
in the spirit back to our country
through these bright young SMA students
and with our Singaporean colleagues we
seek to build a world-class alliance in
engineering education and research in
Singapore through special emphasis on
techno preneur ship we will be strong
team players in Singapore's t21
initiative
we aim to have a positive impact on all
three universities which host us not
least MIT through enhancing the reach
and worldview of its faculty and through
this close association with two other
outstanding faculty and student bodies
halfway around the world
[Music]
well let me let me let me just make a
few final remarks on the way we view
things now where we're headed how we
feel about it first of all we're
discovering many a number of advantages
we hadn't even thought very much about
coming out of it one of them is that our
faculty who use all these modern
PowerPoint slides and new approaches to
education
other than the old blackboard that all
of us were used to are finding that
these same kind the same kind of
preparation these same kind of materials
can liven up the class that they teach
here a great deal secondly we've been
developing a number of cross
departmental interdepartmental subjects
bringing faculty together from a variety
of different departments I haven't had a
chance to go into that but but those new
subjects are going to impact our own
education here we've had a number of of
course already joint research
publications even as well as some
exciting ideas coming out of the
collaborations that we that we've
developed and one company even
about-to-be to be formed between our
people here and and there we've been
using up until now the distance
education room in dick Larson's shop
which he'll be talking about but as we
as we gear up that won't be nearly
enough and so we're renovating other
rooms one 390 for those of you who might
be from civil engineering probably 66
110 before long and and several others
by the time we get done both for for SMA
and for the similar alliance that will
be developing with Cambridge University
will will have four or five distance
education rooms at well several million
dollars a piece is what they is what
they cost I could cite other advantages
on the mi MIT side let me simply give
you a one example of how Singapore views
this the National University of
Singapore the main university the the
most prestigious university has
just inaugurated its new president man
named Fung she was inaugurated two days
ago on June 1 and his speech that he
gave was quite a marvelous document in
where the he wanted education and NUS to
go in the future and and highlighted in
that speech was the role that MIT is
playing and that they're playing jointly
with us so with that thank you and I
turn the mic over to dick Larsen well
good afternoon everybody
it's nice to see all these red blazers
here I'm 15 years from that event myself
you know God will I'm looking forward to
that
but thank you so much for coming those
of you who are with red blazes I'd like
to keep it around of applause I'm class
of 65 so I also know it's the 35th
anniversary for that the 35th reunion
for that class and I see some friends
here in the audience so I'm gonna ask
Chuck you there you hear me okay what
was new on the campus at that time and
what would be being broadcast on it at
this very hour if we were listening this
is - Chuck McCallum - see now retired
from AT&T
Lucent Bell Labs I can't remember what
which one of this was was our head Penn
Station right
yeah FM station does anyone recall what
the original call letters were you got
it of course we know where to WTBS
currently is in Atlanta Georgia it's in
Atlanta Georgia well so welcome all of
those of you who are at different
reunions I'm happy to say to MIT is very
similar to I can guarantee this to
Christ Minster those who get stay here
for five years and and then graduate
certainly graduate with quote no corrupt
passion its unquote so so with that if
you believe that okay what we're going
to be talking about today is a
continuation of what Mirta
was was discussing with the very
exciting and innovative SMA program i'm
had the privilege to direct this the
center for advanced educational services
cas for five years and this will be a
little bit of a tour of what we've been
up to but also nationally
internationally what some of the current
developments are and let's have a
context for distance education there are
many virtual universities right now
where you can get degrees bachelor's
master's PhDs we heard about walden
university out of naples florida you'd
never notice from Naples Florida you go
to their website that happens to be
their snail mail address but you can get
the PhD from anywhere by by
corresponding with them there are many
corporate universities over 1000 now
corporate university it's not just a
McDonald's hamburger you some of these
are quite serious and you can also get
degrees from them about particularly
master's and PhD degrees from some of
these corporate universities in the
private sector Glen Stralis here in the
audience and he and his son and the
others who keep a record adding two or
three companies per week to an Excel
spreadsheet of for-profit companies who
are providing various kinds of products
and services in the educational sector
and then we have the internet which
allows the communication between places
and if you don't believe the Economist
when they said five years ago distance
is dead look at what Merck flemeth just
showed you was Singapore we bring the
Singaporean students in their own MIT
Cambridge based classroom
daily routinely during the school year
and and bite out by videoconferencing by
television and how do we do that TV
image by the by the Internet not by
satellite
not by ISDN or something else that's
internet television using the Internet
to so from a university's point of view
we have huge risks and huge
opportunities I tend to be an optimist
so I see these as huge opportunities
others might see those huge risks so
just to give you an example and some of
these new things that are happening in
higher education happened before the
internet so we can't blame the internet
on things if these are a little bit you
know innovative or upsetting professor
Tom eager at MIT used to be department
head in material science he has a course
on welding which is very very popularly
used to be taught at seven o'clock in
the morning over breakfast and some
General Motors students who are
continuing education students in
Michigan really liked his course and
registered for the course and it was
part of the activity so the students
would come and the GM students continued
education master's science students at
GM would combine Tom Eagers course with
others from RPI Purdue Columbia and
University of Arizona to get their
master's degree from Purdue so mix and
match and that's been going on now for
seven years
national technological university by the
way who knows the largest private
university in the country today what it
is
University Phoenix do you know how many
students they have it's more like eighty
five thousand right now University of
Phoenix distributed in many many states
committing to Massachusetts right now
has a distance learning component as
well as on-campus component for these
campuses are distributed around it's
growing at about twenty four percent per
year their distance learning part is
growing at almost 50 percent per year a
wholly owned subsidiary of the Apollo
Group NASDAQ symbol apol has always made
money every quarter okay so that's
interesting the way things are changing
isn't it now national technological
university which was born in about 1969
or so the oldest satellite TV university
before the internet there
internet-savvy no but they still use
satellite they broadcast credit and not
for credit courses from brick-and-mortar
universities and including MIT on
occasion they graduate about 160
master's students per year in the
average student has taken courses from
seven different brick-and-mortar
universities perhaps including MIT you
might ask what do they learn on average
their grade point average on a four
point scale is point three higher than
the corresponding brick-and-mortar
student counterparts University learning
networks I think SMA is an example that
where we're now expanding the ideas to
expand the university off the campus and
join like-minded folks and universities
elsewhere MIT is tied to Singapore is
certainly an exemplar of that and a
leading edge exemplar we're about to get
involved with the University of
Cambridge in the UK and do a similar
scale thing but but they have different
different aspects to it including junior
year abroad for fifty of our students so
we're likely to have soon not this
coming academic year but the one after
that fifty MIT students spend junior
year abroad at University of Cambridge
and vice versa 50 of them would come
here we'll have some distance learning
back and forth across the pond as they
say there's the MIT Singapore alliance
you saw all that before but it is as
Mert said the world's largest
point-to-point this is learning and
research collaboration program that
we're aware of and the largest
industrial-strength use of Internet to
electronic cross registration for many
many years
Harvard MIT and Wellesley have shared
the courtesy of cross registration for
their students and I think this is
mutual respect and geographical
proximity and so I typically might have
students across the register at Harvard
or have I have some Harvard students in
some of my classes but now the need for
two graphical proximity to do that is
dead you can electronically cross
register using the internet and and
that's happening more and more and there
are websites if you know you're
interested I can give them to you you
can see hundreds of courses on the web
so local monopolies supported by
geography are vanishing one could
speculate there could be an entrepreneur
who
might have $100,000,000 or two maybe two
or three who might want to buy 500 acres
in Costa Rica or some other pleasant
warm place and build a campus and lots
of facilities athletic and teaching and
learning and vite lots of mentors down
there including recently retired folks
maybe maybe professors on sabbatical
from brick-and-mortar universities and a
lot of musicians and artists and poets
and also put up a sign saying this is an
Ivy League plus IB plus place it's going
to be it's just so hard to get into as
Harvard MIT or Princeton or Stanford and
you come here and you're learning will
even be better than any of those places
because you can take your your classes
from best in class let me know regular
faculty here there'll be lots of adult
mentors to transition you between age 18
and 22 independently operating adult but
the classes you take will be from all
those Ivy Plus universities over
internet - and there you go this is just
pure speculation but I wouldn't be
surprised to see something like this
announced within the next five years
somebody might try this another focus
though is that people get confused
between distance learning and what we
call technology enabled education
technology enable education I think is
more interesting and also benefits the
on-campus students as much as the
off-campus students and basically the
technology enable education is creating
learning environments for our students
that couldn't be created before and
because of the technology that's around
so one of the things and is that if you
this is one of my favorite little
drawings in 1837 the first steam engine
to go on tracks in the United States
went 13 miles between Albany New York
and Schenectady it's called the DeWitt
Clinton this is it an exact replica of
it exist in Dearborn Michigan today
actually touched it a few months ago is
out there in the Ford Museum and so they
had the steam engine they had the tracks
but nobody had given any thought to well
I think we have to tow something here we
have this thing called railroad cars but
nobody had designed them so the other
thing they could think of as
stagecoaches so they took these
stagecoaches they took the horses away
and puts it put the wheels on so they
say they'd be ridged they'd stay on them
and in a sense that's what we're doing
now and a lot of distance learning we're
taking the chalk and talk passive West
lectures mode that's been the primary
mode of teaching and learning in
universities for centuries and putting
it on to this 21st century technology so
you might call it twelfth century
teaching in the 21st century
technological environment and so there's
a lot of centuries to catch up and a lot
of things we can do differently now and
that's a very exciting kind of Applied
Research and then MIT isn't involved in
that in a lot of different ways and so
the words on the left are the kind of
words that we thought of we were taught
when we went through MIT and the words
on the right are kind of new words which
is a learner focus active learning
asynchronous or synchronous learning
accomplishing a goal rather than
teaching the students material these
sorts of things and there's lots of
experimentation in this past year MIT is
virtually exploded with us with with the
d'arbeloff funds and high campus funds
from a Microsoft Alliance and there are
many faculty around now who are doing
very very innovative interesting things
in this area we're also interested in
that area applied to lifelong learning
and particularly for this audience
looking to our alumni to see what the
alumni would like to have from MIT in
terms of lifelong connection to MIT
perhaps using the Internet as the
primary connecting vehicle the research
I was talking about is basically how do
you match pedagogy and technology so you
can get a specific knowledge domain it
can be calculus it can be Shakespeare or
whatever it is into a into a best
learning environment for whatever group
you're talking about it's if its alumni
if it's if it's college undergraduates
if it's k12 and this matching of
pedagogy with technology to deliver a
certain knowledge domain to a certain
set of learners is an active very very
fast-growing active research Enterprise
here at MIT and bringing in a lot of
disciplines that you wouldn't think
might might apply there including my own
discipline of operations research now
one of the areas where we're doing some
really innovative stuff is in
Shakespeare you wouldn't believe that's
what Professor Peter Donaldson has an
online video archive an image in Archive
and allowing the students at MIT to
learn Shakespeare in this way if I had
more time I would explain more details
but we can we can do that after
you like we also have most of you
remember what 801 is okay freshman
physics one of the one of the hardest
courses on campus it still has a 15
percent failure rate
unfortunately down slightly this past
this past year and so we're trying to
focus on that and created a better
learning environment there a lot of some
students who can afford it actually
higher human tutors so what we try to do
is create a virtual tutor on the web and
that's the pivot project and there's
professor Walter Lewin teaching this
thing physics interactive video tutor
it's a million dollar project it was
funded primarily from an anonymous donor
plus equipment from IBM and basically we
have a keyword you you take a keyword
and you you click on it and it'll show
you all kinds of media from from from
little snippets of lectures or from
Professor Liu and working out problems
to other kinds of things that can help
you the real-life professor blue and
maybe sleeping to three o'clock in the
morning but you can bring them up on
your on your desktop in your dorm room
or your fraternity it's a highly
interactive student directed nonlinear
learning environment means that no two
students Traverse this in the same way
and it's got loads of helpful things on
it
professor John Belcher the physics
department has more than a million
dollars now a dedicated and allocated to
teaching electromagnetism 802 in better
ways to better ways one animation
simulation visualization here's an
example right here and also studio
learning they're going to ban large
lectures out of 26100 in about a year or
so for 802 and they're gonna have very
active studio environments where the
students learn electromagnetism by
accomplishing goals by sitting in
partnerships at the computer in various
learning environments real virtual lab
now there's a picture of an old lab but
we have professor hey-zeus to Alamo tecs
who now has a micro electronics lab on
the web and we've had students from
Singapore part of the SMA program
actually conduct micro electronics
experiments at MIT by setting up the lab
equipment automatically on the web from
Singapore so we have a research question
if you had some weight
web-based tutors that have laboratory
experience animation simulation people
talking at you with you answering
questions would this really improve
learning and so this is one of the
central research areas that we're
looking at so to you our alumni we have
some questions we think that a number of
us think that MIT shouldn't focus next
its major next strategic initiative and
distance learning to you folks I mean
you're here for four years or five years
I'm glad to hear that so we're hoping in
the QA we might get some response from
you as to what you would like what you
would like here's some examples what
postgraduate educational services would
have been or would be now useful to you
and can we talk about it and so here's
some options one we could have the whole
course catalog all these courses
available to you on the Internet I don't
think that would be that that
interesting but there's one example we
could have these short intensive
one-week professional Institute summer
session things available to you that way
we could have something which we've
called MIT world MIT world would be a 24
hour day seven day week TV station on
the internet showing you what's going on
at MIT that week our best lectures
events public colloquia and seminars
broadcast you user protected of password
protected so only you are alumni could
see these things I mean we would go with
the hackers as they climb up on the dome
and do the latest things I like that
active learning modules for updating you
and your majors or getting you
accustomed to new things like molecular
biology or how about this for a thing
you've heard of the HMO how about an e
mo educational maintenance organization
have your employer donate to this on a
monthly basis tax advantage menu of a
cafeteria count and from that you can
have both emergency care and regular
care from MIT so we can talk about all
those things I have if I have time if I
don't wear a watch so I never know how
late I am but if we have to I have a
five minute video I'd like to summarize
this a real presentation what do we have
time to do we have time to do that let's
do the five minute video okay mit one of
the world's pre-eminent research
universities known for both educational
excellence and cutting edge research
dedicated to advancing knowledge and
educating students in science technology
and other areas of scholarship mit
educating for the future graduate
students in mi t--'s system design and
management program or STM are trained to
become engineers who can lead instructed
through video conference and web-based
courses as well as on-campus sessions
these practicing engineers learn a
holistic view of systems and new product
development the Institute's first degree
granting distance education program STM
Awards master's degrees jointly given by
mi t--'s schools of engineering and
management
using leading-edge technologies the
Singapore MIT Alliance is pioneering a
new standard for global collaboration in
graduate engineering education and
research MIT and Singapore's two leading
universities the National University of
Singapore and nan yang technological
university are working together to
develop and deliver programs to students
12 time zones away students learn from
materials including live and archived
video available 24 hours a day via
internet - if you're in the right place
at the right time you are watching a
course on Internet commerce working
professionals
now lifelong learners can also take
educational programs from MIT while
they're at work in partnership with PBS
the Business Channel mi t--'s Centre for
advanced educational services provides
non-credit professional development to
thousands of learners may be quick
adapter students receive video based
education on their computer desktops
ruin their company's training centers
via satellite broadcast and streaming
web video
[Music]
what if students could customize
web-based class materials to fit their
own learning styles mi t--'s hypermedia
teaching facility creates and evaluates
new types of desktop education to give
students a richer more interactive
learning experience directed by dr.
nishikado-san walker hdf also instructs
on campus and remote participants from
industry government and universities in
creating learning applications and why
the web is a good choice imagine having
your favorite professor around to answer
your questions any time day or night I'm
finding on to pivot now again number one
mi t--'s physics interactive video tutor
does just that the pivot project
directed by Professor Richard Larsen
lets students have virtual conversations
with physics professor Walter Lewin and
you can even ask the question which both
the speed on an interactive website
students ask questions and receive video
tutorials customized specifically for
their needs I would like to do a
demonstration and show this to you but
ultimately you will have to do it
in the future if you can't come to the
lab the lab will come to you
professor Hayes Estelle Alamo and his
team are making a real micro electronics
testing laboratory available online to
students from anywhere at any time 24
hours a day this will revolutionize
science and engineering education by
providing greater access to
state-of-the-art labs including at other
institutions making sense of complex
content such as foreign culture is a
challenging task with the hypermedia
documentary barely knows n students can
investigate cultural material from
multiple perspectives create their own
mini documentaries and collaborate with
other students the program developed by
dr. Curt vents and Miss Ellen Crocker
features on location video and authentic
historical documents depicting Berlin's
cultural social and political life now
delving to the far east soon you will be
able to travel into 20th century China
with the Longboat China archive a
digital collection of video images
articles even hundreds of hours of music
when complete it will give scholars
access to one of the most comprehensive
visual archives covering the last 100
years of life in China
to be or not to be that is the question
with the Shakespeare electronic archive
students can experience the world's
greatest plays in a brand-new way using
an extensive digital library students
create their own multimedia essays from
early Shakespearean texts as well as
stage and film versions and create a
resource for scholars led by Professor
Peter Donaldson the MIT team has also
created an internet prototype that lets
students share their projects over the
web
future students may learn engineering in
a different way under a model proposed
by MIT aeronautics and astronautics
students will get engineering
fundamentals while also learning
real-world systems and products the
initiative will include an exploration
of distance collaboration in design
courses using desktop video conferencing
as a tool to teach design and
communicate people from remote locations
will work together on common design
projects
[Music]
innovation educational excellence
cutting-edge research MIT educating for
the future
[Music]
okay I do hope during the Q&A we have
some chance to hear from you about what
kinds of educational products and
services you'd like from from MIT thank
you very much that seems like an even
harder act to follow than a than a
linguist if we could we'll tee up here
this this I wanted to start with a
little light motif of Music Hall or
movie house but also show that when we
talk about the future of physical you
that you can actually jam a spellchecker
to the I don't want to make too much a
music hall or movie house the kind of
question of clicks or mortar and what is
the future of the physical University or
is it fiction water was it bricks in
water what's it going to be just brought
to mind as I think David said I have a
bit of a show business background and
and so I think in terms of music halls
and movie houses and so on and if you
think about the University as you know
is it in the situation of a music hall
where a theatre was in the 1920s or
1930s when movies started to come into
view when for example on Broadway there
were three hundred and thirty six shows
playing on a Broadway consistently year
by year in 1927 I think
they were 336 Broadway shows and of
course today there are 20 perhaps many
of the revivals by the way movie houses
because I was a Disney I also thought
about that when we were very worried in
the 1919 80s there were about 20,000
movie screens in the country and we said
boy cable VCR I mean the the video
cassette recorder came in and for the
first time people used their TV more for
watching pre-recorded video cassettes
than they were watching actual TV
program and you had cable coming in and
you had saw a television you said that's
it for the movie business and screens
have gone up pretty consistently two to
four percent per year since so you kind
of say well why is that and in a sense
that's a little bit what's the question
for schools so this is to prove that
that maybe if I'd apply it I might have
come to MIT and been able to do the work
it's kind of an engineering drawing this
is actually borrowed from one of our
professors clay Christensen now I'm
going to do a shameless plug as well if
you haven't read the innovators dilemma
it's a it's a wonderful book it's that
the subtitle here is when new
technologies cause great firms to fail
but you can substitute in firms
organizations institutions schools
because it's kind of interesting just a
week ago the all of you I'm sure
subscribed to USA Today but there was an
article called well business schools
without a business and it talks about
what Merton and Dick were talking about
in terms of technology enabled distance
learning what is this going to do for us
to us and there was this nice quote here
from clay Christensen the author who
said Harvard has become a finishing
school for consultants and investment
bankers
ouch
so you kind of think about that and and
kind of what are you doing now what does
that have to do with this wrong this is
some of clays work in which he's
basically saying that there is a band of
performance that the market wants at any
given time and over time that tends to
move up there are suppliers who have a
kind of a band of competence that they
deliver and that moves up over time and
his primary thesis is and over time you
begin to overshoot what your customers
really want you keep getting better and
better and better at it and that's kind
of his observation about are you really
kind of creating really a probably
business school where I spend time now
are you kind of making it too good you
know too good that you really move away
from the market that you you overshoot
that in fat people you know that we can
bring a lot more into the classroom we
can use a lot more technologies and
we're doing that by the way we really
believe in that make it the best
experience possible but then it also
costs more
it takes more out of people it's maybe
more intense and ultimately the question
becomes is this for the elite few you
know I I don't on Thomas Hardy but who
gets to go to the University then at
that point Andy says you know what
happens inevitably is that alternatives
start to come up often
technology-enabled if he kind of much of
his work was around the computer
industry and he noted that for example
at IBM in the 1970 PC you know this is a
toy it's it's it's really it really
doesn't do what what big blue iron does
and and in fact they're absolutely right
it didn't but it started to pick off
some of these opportunities
these lower elements in the band of
performance that was desired and it
could serve those well and gradually it
got better on its own track and as big
machines were overshooting the market
the small machines got better and better
and eventually you know where would you
rather be these days so it's it's a very
useful kind of metaphor for thinking
about any kind of demand supply
situation in fact I think when we when
we talk about educating about education
certainly when I do I think of the first
customer as being student right and now
why is a student go to get an education
learning skill education learning in
some broad sense everyone went to MIT
for that probably also went to get a
degree to get a credential that they
could use maybe they went to get away
from their parents maybe they went to
find a spouse or it just happened
they got in that work they met some
friends people probably in this room now
who who you've worked together perhaps
in various times in different ways over
10 20 50 years get a job or get a better
job you know yeah I went too slowly on
the education we want to get a good job
and in fact you should get a better job
in 1980 28% of the students learners in
the post-secondary environment were
under the age of 25
in 1995 43 % of them they've either gone
out and worked coming back getting a
better job get alive get an identity I
think I think all of us probably here
think about their MIT Association is a
very important part of who they are and
what they are and what they will do and
have done I certainly feel that way
about my alma mater so the point here
being sure there's many more as well
that when you think about that
performance demand what is it that
people are looking for
we think immediately education in the
university context particularly the
undergraduate level I think it can be
quite quite a mix of things and indeed
there are other customers of the
university their corporation in in
thinking in looking at your website I
found that MIT has some 300 million
dollars annually of funded research and
as we all know tuition itself if we
think about the student as the customer
the the student pays for less than half
that even the most robust level you know
at any university may be half of what it
costs to run the place probably somewhat
less increasingly less MIT as a Research
Institute has done you know realized
importantly and is what can I do there
was a subtle message in this shirt by
the way I don't know if you can read
this but this docent which is one of
these learning platforms that Harvard
Business School publishing just did a
deal with and they pay me two dollars
and fifty cents every time I wear the
shirt in public so there are
corporations and government as we said
in that three hundred million dollars of
funding research very big part of what
the university is and in since a
customer of the University their alumni
indeed I don't know of any top-tier
institution who doesn't succeed without
the support of the Alumni even noticed
on that same MIT site that you're in the
midst of a 1.5 billion dollar
fundraising campaign one of the things
that that that dick pointed to and and
and where I think there really is this
kind of disruptive quality to what's
going on now and dick slides I thought
were terrific and in laying out 600
companies in the for-profit world I mean
and the technology enable versus
distance-learning they're in david's
early comments about some of these
companies and Apollo being kind of the
largest you know enrollment well I guess
85,000 will put it right up there there
may be a couple of state universities
that are there at that range - but
there's something fundamentally
different going on with the pedagogy
when you go towards technology enable
and particularly e-learning or distance
learning which is that in the in the
kind of traditional model we have a that
the country the intellectual expertise
and the delivery of the intellectual
expertise is embodied in one person so
typically you have someone who really
knows their stuff and it's someone so
sports on now they may have teaching
assistants and they'll use other
materials and so on but in the
technology world that unbundled and
there's a new role you have the
intellectual capital creation the
expertise you have the instructional
designer which other son is a new role
that frankly is very uncomfortable for
certainly for the content expert because
it's giving up it's it's giving ceding
control over to this new entity and the
delivery can also be unbundled once you
instructionally design something someone
else can deliver your course and so
fundamentally you you you really you
start now to get folks that specialize
in different and those in those
different capabilities and that creates
change the big question of course as
this evolves is will new technologies
displace traditional suppliers of
learning is it a threat and Dick
referred to you know an optimist or a
pessimist it's it's a kind of reminds re
one quick joke but it's the the story
what's an optimist when they see a glass
of water and it's filled to the
mid-level it is
a full and a pessimist is and a
reengineering consultant twice as much
glass as you need so will we displace
the existing supply or will the demand
for learning increase in a sense if we
go back to that chart are there is there
this under this level of demand or in
the disaggregating are there good enough
applications and specialized
applications that people will will will
want
I'm also an optimist
I think I'm by the way my answer that is
is both I mean I I think I think some
people I think some universities are
going to be hammered it's interesting
you know there was one closure I guess
Bradford I didn't I didn't know Bradford
but you can't see that last week or a
few weeks ago and I kind of said oh it's
it's it's happening and then at the same
time there was a there's a new
engineering school that's being
announced Olin and anybody know about
this one well apparently they're going
to fund it but you do maybe you okay
yeah they're going to fund in perpetuity
free tuition for every one who goes
there
kind of an interesting idea so clearly
this is a space that is going to shake
up and you know the kind of question is
where will you come out I don't mean by
that MIT I think I think you're pretty
clear on that I mean there is what are
the options you've not talked about
research focus institution but clearly
you're a full-service institution
service provider when I said full social
service provider it was kind of
referring back to the transformational
process that particularly the
undergraduate level that that I think
students want or at least some segment
of the student population wants local
market resellers if you think about you
know smaller schools that don't have
rapid
that don't have world-class faculty what
are the choices open to them they can
become a local market reseller of
materials course materials produced by
others because as you think about that
whereas capital intellectual capital
created whereas it instructionally
designed and kind of made into in the
old days textbooks but now I'm not
something much more robust that it can
be delivered potentially locally and and
by the way the the distance learning and
technology enable learning is not about
the death of the teacher it's not about
the removal of what has been called
human wear from the educational process
because the most successful programs and
I would predict this here will be
hybrids of both and they will take
advantage of the personalization that
technology can provide of the
communities of interest on the fly that
it can provide of the rupture of time
and space synchronicity but the single
most important thing to date and all
eLearning experiments has been the
quality of interaction of the learner
with the human intervention with the
teacher the facilitator the instructor
the professor specialized learning
centers or something else so where will
it come out that's something that every
school is going to have to decide and it
sounds as though it's something you
always thinking out just to kind of a
last kind of footnote to close out
they're approximately 3,700
post-secondary institutions representing
two hundred and forty billion dollar
annual flow ninety-eight percent of that
is not for profit David to you thanks
[Applause]
well that was terrific
let's just have some questions and let's
see if we can get some differences of
opinion dollars available production
distributed packer final is unchanged to
some degree so what we've seen in some
cases is a reduction in the production
budgets where many
I'm not sure hardly question but I guess
if I think about demand its its global
for example I think what you see with
MIT going to Singapore that's something
that wouldn't happen I mean that to me
that represents arguably new demand
I think the continuous learning cycle I
mean people know that this is that if
they want that the economy is moving on
it's much more of a knowledge economy
and it sounds trite but it's very very
true people you know the half-life of
information is shorter they know they
need to come back they can get it in
bite-sized chunks without the
residential requirement for it so
they're you know they're it's just more
accessible gosh I mean I think people
will just simply want more because it's
more accessible and I mean I really
think we're already seeing the evidence
of that my guess is that is that the
first big wave will be much more in
corporate spending whether it's in the
technical area in the engineering areas
or whether it's in there certainly in
the market that I spend most of my time
thinking about is management science
yeah it's just it on that it's it's a
really interesting question about about
who will pay for it we looked at this
the average out and the average
managerial person will spend 321 dollars
of their own money per year on education
that will change dramatically if for
example I know that
a C++ if I can program in C++ or
director Macromedia I can get a ten
thousand dollar salary in degrees so so
I think the economics will in the first
way will be very much driven by the
employment market how do you start to
tap into the things that are available
now okay well a lot of alumni who I've
spoken with said that they they really
want to come back to MIT but they want
to do it from their current residence
where copy colorado california florida
or wherever not just on their some
reunion that divides by five or ten from
from their class and talking about this
the idea of these public seminars in
colloquia and special events if we could
broadcast the most the most wide-ranging
of those the things that we think would
be most interesting to you would you be
interested in that what we call at MIT
world would you
well if you go to the Alumni MIT Alumni
Association website as of either this
past week or next week we will have on
there some very interesting videos for
you that are archival from our history
including Winston Churchill's visit to
MIT in the late 40s etc etc however so
you do think that this MIT world might
be interesting if we have like a TV
guide a guide to it show a hour by hour
through the week 24 hours a day and
we're not gonna have 24 hours a day new
content but we might have maybe six to
eight new lectures special events and
event you know like if I kiss occurred
here today some of these events there
for you well so how many think this
might be interesting to you okay I'm
happy to announce that this will become
a reality September 1st of this year if
I could just finish this not to be
facetious what we are currently doing
now there's a joint program proposal
from the Alumni Association from
corporate relations headed by Carl Costa
and my Center CIS and we are seeking
five corporate founding partners to fund
this at $100,000 per year for the firm
for the first year this to do this will
cost us $500,000 and I'm happy to
announce that we have the first
signatory this this week and we have two
others that are just about to sign so
we're just looking for two more we hope
to be able to close this out on June
30th even if we don't have all five
we're gonna go alive anyway in in
September with maybe a reduced thing and
get then get this going so this will be
up for you this will be offered by those
three programs the ILP corporate
relations and the Alumni Association NCA
s as of September this year and we're
hoping this is just the first of many
many educational products and services
this will be available to you for no
charge in
we do send us emails the class of 50
would you like we will when it's
announced this is the first public
announcement of this today so we don't
we haven't had a yeah 500,000 money one
year passes one year so we'll have to
find five hundred thousand dollars every
year to do this what is this product on
the MIT campus during the school year
from September through May if you go to
Tech Talk if you read Tech Talk or Tech
Talk is now on the web so you can go see
Tech Talk on the web you can go to the
MIT webpages and see it there are
announced every week many many public
seminars talks special events colloquy
that are open to the public and the
typical attendance at these things is 20
to 50 I would say and sometimes we bring
in the Sloan School brings in CEOs of
Fortune 100 companies would bring in
dignitaries dignitaries from from from
other countries or faculty members here
are talking about breakthroughs and
bioengineering or something like this
one reason that we can't put that on a
public access website is because of the
myriad copyright problems with all of
that video and imaging content there are
like three or four hundred copyright
holders of all the stuff that we have
here under the fair use doctrine we can
use that for our on-campus students but
it's that we put it on the web we have
to clear all those copyrights and that
is a problem that every major university
is having right now and we're hoping
that maybe Congress or the universities
themselves and get together with
copyright holders and come up with some
clearinghouses substantive way of
dealing with us right now that's a real
problem but it's Shakespeare content
like a lecture and then I think dick and
I probably are going to give you about
the same answer on that and that is that
a lot of us both on the legal side of
the house and on the academic side of
the house and on the administration side
of the house are trying to figure out
what to do about that right now well at
CES where we have to produce things and
distribute them often under business
models that at least break even
sometimes actually create positive
revenue which we reinvest in the other
educational products and services we
have the faculty signed contracts with
us and the contracts typically separate
the realization of a particular hour
let's say on from our TV studios with
the realization of an hour where they
might be talking about e-commerce or
supply chain management or project
management or something like that that
that hour that's from our TV studios and
the compression of it on the on the on
the web and the related website MIT owns
the copyright to however the
intellectual content that went into that
hour the faculty member retains
ownership of and we've had very few
faculty members have any problem signing
that kind of arrangement yeah we have no
general can we sort of stay in that
week's
even for severe vomiting colitis that
along with the Alumni Association side
sounds like so why one of the
implications of it is to then have a
database with everyone who's on for life
so that you can notify people and also
when you vote it will have a homepage
which we'll talk about
you can quickly link with things going
on at the Institute so it will become a
base from which we can do but these
things do take time and take some money
and we've got about thirty twenty
thousand alumni who are now dependent on
email forwarding for life we don't have
backup in maintenance whatever we could
have a real disaster these things are
much simpler to talk about yes go to a
different area that has two discussed
here that is a undergraduate education I
understand that you know they're going
to be a lot of corporate and wonder we
can address you know what we could be
are reading revolutionary change
having basically undergraduate school on
campus of radius-r all camels
you can onyx let's take you spoke to
that work most directly in terms that
minutes okay so some of what i talked
about and some of what was in the video
that I showed talked very specifically
about undergraduates 801 is really
changing because of the pivot project
802 is changing because of visualization
animation simulation and then studio
courses by the way studio courses were
made popular by studio courses I mean
there's no large lectures and the
students meet for three hours at once a
week in a technology enabled
reconfigurable classroom that typically
has 70 to 80 students one faculty member
who is allowed to speak only for five
minutes the beginning that's it and then
the students usually sit in pairs or
triples or quarter or a force in front
of a computer that has software that's
very user friendly that is set up to
help them achieve a goal during those
three hours to show that their expertise
in that knowledge in that theory or
whatever by achieving a goal in that
technology enabled environment that was
made popular at RPI in the midden in the
mid nineties and Jack Wilson and others
at RPI they won every conceivable award
for for innovation in an undergraduate
teaching in in engineering universities
so the studio model is what we're trying
now with with 802 and John Dolce there
is a revolution going a positive
revolution going on the MIT campus
because now with the Microsoft money
from the I campus initiative which is
five million dollars a year and the
d'arbeloff funds which are which are
going in this area as well and some
others some Provost discretionary money
there's in the order of magnitude of
seven to eight million dollars a year
that are being focused on on campus
education and learning the huge majority
that being undergraduate so the very
exciting thing is you have you have
faculty members from virtually every one
of the five schools now who have bought
into this and who are
viewing the idea of how my students
learn as an interesting intellectual
challenge so in addition to the usual
research they're good they're going to
do research on that for perhaps the
first time in their life and and explore
some of these new venues so I think if
you think of that going on for five
years five years from now this would be
a much different place in terms of
teaching and learning and hopefully much
improved people who want to do that
although there are these international
networking arrangements with research
and teaching like we have with the SMA
program we're about to have with the
University of Cambridge in the UK but I
haven't heard anyone talk about MIT
opening a West Coast branch or a branch
in another continent for undergraduate
education let me let me give you the
sense of the faculty as I understand it
at this time and that is that MIT would
not want to give a degree at any level
without to a person without that person
spending and a major part of the
educational activity here on campus
that's true even at the graduate level
where I don't know what the ratio is it
will do it now maybe maybe a master's
degree half out half in but
undergraduate I I think that the ratio
would have to be very largely on campus
in terms of the current sense of the
faculty and the institution so so that
means the brics aspect of this is really
very important that it's not scalable
well it it that is the future is the
future but I believe that's the sense of
the faculty right now that the MIT
diploma which you all have and I have is
is something that came from not only the
lecture but the but the culture that we
that we have here and so far as I know
the the sense of the faculty is that the
world has not progressed far enough in a
that we should change that they start to
talk to me and they start to tell me
that suddenly they understand what the
difference is I'll never be able to
explain it to their boss they despair
being into their boss maybe I'm
old-fashioned and you're old-fashioned
there is something about the on-campus
experience that can't be replaced the
growth of a Kadeem is real the dark side
is very very serious
the companies want the students to work
full-time at their job and do an MIT
education we've had divorces we've had
people deliveries we have to keep in
mind that from the outside this may look
very different than the way it looks on
the inside and we just want to say that
I I totally agree there's so much to
learn in this area and there's in this
very different kinds of distance
education to others the SDM program
which which goes out to separate
companies in in multiple locations
there's the Singapore program which is
very different where they do have a home
and a cohort and there are other models
too that we'll we'll be experimenting
with over the years ahead the fact that
we're not planning to open a West Coast
version of MIT doesn't mean that we
don't have some plans to take these new
educational technology products and
service
have some leadership impact nationally
internationally the green book series
which came out of the electron
engineering department in late 50s and
early 60s redefine the teaching of
engineering is engineering science it
was motivated primarily by the
experience in world war two and then
Sputnik World War two where the inputs
into applied R&D in a fast environment
by electro engineers were woefully
inadequate compared to what the
physicists were doing and that was felt
that the we weren't training engineers
from a general perspective anyway make a
long story short we had a major impact
on teaching of engineering education
late 50s early 60s result the green book
series have been several of the series
since then if you could think about it
today the pivot project for instance the
electromagnetism work we're doing there
are plans for distributing those with a
business model analogous to what a
publisher would do previously but now
it's a web-based product service and we
hope that the pivot project that for
instance the pivot thing might be
available to students at a hundred
different colleges and universities a
year from now
in fact we're experimenting in the fall
not only with MIT students but also
Wellesley students and RPI students who
are all are going to have access to two
pivot
[Music]
to go to 88 so he graduated from high
school in does anybody knows if the
current eighteen-year-old know or how
many of the current 18 year olds have a
desire to go to this shining University
or are they completely happy with what I
as an adult who has had so many rich
experiences particularly at a small
women's college where I got my science
degree do these contemporary young
people feel enthralled with this more
highly technical computerized video eyes
wonderful right learning but are you
going to be able to get them involved in
on campus which
you know I think there must be as many
different kinds of undergraduates as
their I of all the rest of us but the
kids who come to MIT they love it it
seemed to me there were several things
in what you were saying but they they
they love the pressure the way they
always did they love it and they hate it
but they're here for it and they and
they know it's here they love the new
things they love the educational
technologies now that's on the distance
but they isn't isn't the work that the
admissions committee generalized
continues University
you know there are well there is some
fifty thousand fifty six thousand
students a year with with what SAT score
is above fourteen hundred I think it is
and and and those fifty six thousand
students are most of them trying to get
into the top ten universities the
admissions committees have at the best
universities Harvard included
have have two jobs that's that's that's
to pick out the right ones out of that
pool because they're all so bright and
the right ones you they define that in a
lot of different ways appropriately it's
to pick out the right ones but then it's
to attract them to I there's two parts
of that job is to is to choose and then
attract and the same with the Singapore
project yeah I'm not too much worried
about the burden and my students it's so
let's take another model that
corresponds a little bit about the
question about undergraduate education
let's take a Midwestern State University
where's the state mandates that anybody
who graduates from high school has to be
admitted in their studying computer
science or something like that some of
them probably the very good
but that's cuz merck pushed me this well
I think first of all MIT doesn't
necessarily see that surprises roll
contribute directly to those University
of those institutions however even
without that being the central part of
my t's role let's take the pivot project
which you mentioned half of the 1
million dollars that we spent creating
pivot was to create a general generic
software infrastructure that supports a
video tutor so we have that now so we
can populate it with any content we want
we have started creating that for 1806
linear algebra with professor Gill
Strang I know we're not going to teach
that at this course either but but the
the lecture part of that by the way is
freely available on the web to you right
now you go see you can learn linear
algebra the entire grant into the entire
course which is more than most popular
undergraduate math elected when the MIT
campus I think 45% where students take
it we could populate it with Shakespeare
we're going to next year start with Paul
Gray former president chairman of the
board is gonna be teaching circuit
theory and we're gonna create a video
tutor for that however you could create
a video tutor for algebra 1 or algebra 2
or precalculus or whatever else those
colleges need
and then from one of those schools to
[Music]
your University University yeah we have
a little bit of experience at friend
from the publishing perspective and at
Harvard Business School on that we're
we're we've been doing essentially
distance learning but the correspondence
way by producing effectively 90% of the
cases that are used in the case method
Business School management education
programs well 90% of the cases used are
ours we sell about 6 million of these
cases per year I think the short answer
is the student can only benefit if the
institution wants em to because they
have access to really high-class best
minds and production then you hope that
you know you've you've been structurally
designed it in a rich way that the
student can only benefit part of the
issue that I think is whose faculty as
much as who is the student to faculty
let it in there's there's an
organization called eCollege I don't
know if you've kind of dealt with them
much but that's exactly what they do
there are a couple of kind of competing
platforms are now going to typically
state universities community colleges
smaller schools and saying we'll give
you
and an internet platform will give you
essentially an electronic platform and
we're working we're we're encouraging in
some cases we're funding the creation of
great materials sometimes not so great
but aspiring to be as as good as they
can be and better than what would
otherwise be offered or perhaps
something that's not even offered at all
you know if there's no Russian Studies
program well here's you know you can do
that if that you know if L in a gap sort
of thing my sense is that kind of back
to an earlier question that the student
learner can can only benefit if the
institutional forces will will permit
this through and certainly MIT could do
that as you were saying you have talked
about proliferation of competition with
private universities that are springing
up the possibility of an Ivy League
university online or whatever what
should be the University's position on
allowing its professors or their
professors to participate with some of
these other opportunities they offer
money to the professors they want the
best names from places like
should the research universities be
concerned about their professors doing
this do they have to be concerned about
their own reputation or other where
their professors being spread thin I
don't mean to treat that one too lately
but it's awfully late in the day to ask
[Laughter]
it seems like a lot of universities have
moved as quickly as the opportunities
from the outside and that they may be a
little bit behind I think that's correct
mr. chairman may I make one closing
remark I just want to say that I've been
looking at those wonderful red coats out
there picturing you all as those
grown-up sophomores when I came in
and I want you to know you've hardly
changed at all
[Applause]